[Musica]
[Applauso]
Wow
immaginate un ragazzo di circa 17 anni
seduto in fondo alla classe
svogliato smagrito inerte
un tipo buono ma che sembra indifferente
al mondo che attorno pare non risponde
agli stimoli senza forza di volontà
senza desideri
che ansia
immaginate adesso di vederlo rientrare
in classe
triste dopo l'ennesimo richiamo nello
studio della preside che gli ha appena
comunicato che si andrà avanti così sarà
bocciato Che angoscia
immaginate adesso di essere il suo
insegnante in piedi alla cattedra
lo vedete rientrare in classe triste
Cosa fate cosa dirgli come agireste
non vi pare una bella sfida
sentiamo tutti la sfida dell'ambiente
della sostenibilità della cura del
pianeta sentiamo la sfida della pandemia
della infodemia sentiamo la sfida della
violenza della guerra sentiamo la sfida
del lavoro delle preoccupazioni
quotidiane delle bollette
Ecco Oggi vorrei parlarvi di una sfida
che per me è la più decisiva tra tutte
queste
e che chiede la nostra attenzione si
tratta della sfida
dell'ecologia dell'umano
cioè dell'emergenza educativa
cioè della Paideia integrale Grazie
la sfida della Paideia una parola greca
bellissima integrale di Uomini e Donne
che daranno realtà al futuro
si tratta della sfida cioè di far
fiorire ogni adolescente
sto parlando di quel miracolo che è il
diventare se stesso di ciascuno di noi
attraverso quel passaggio cruciale che è
l'adolescenza che io chiamo fioritura Ma
in cosa consiste questa fioritura voi
ciascuno di voi
quando ha compreso se stesso
quando e come avete preso il vostro
posto nel mondo
Io penso ad Andrea che dicevo ma penso a
Valeria che in terza dopo un'inaspettato
crollo emotivo grazie alla paziente e
amorevole compagnia mia e di altri
colleghi è riuscita a rimettersi in
cammino a riprendere il lavoro a
studiare
e pensa a Diego che non so per quale
motivo aveva scelto di farla finita con
la scuola e aveva deciso di farsi
bocciare lui di fronte la decisione
inaspettata nostra di docenti di
promuoverlo con quattro debiti di fronte
a questa stima immeritata questa
possibilità che non si aspettava ha
deciso di rimettersi a studiare a
passati i debiti è diventato tra i
migliori della classe per poi scegliere
di diventare maestro elementare
e penso Penso agli irruente Simone che
all'inizio dell'anno ripassando Platone
in classe primi giorni dal fondo della
classe Alza la mano e dice Prof ma
allora Esistono le idee
Simone è lì non era più un bambino ma un
soggetto che iniziava a concepire
problemi di una portata universale
e poi penso a Luca molto intelligente ma
anche molto disilluso giacinico che dopo
quattro anni di scuola quest'estate
grazie alla continua proposta di
insegnanti e compagni arriva a dire prof
non vedo l'ora di tornare in classe di
rimettermi al lavoro perché ho capito
che bello accettare la sfida del
diventare grande
ecco
di fronte a tutte queste sfide
difficoltà complessità quando era un
giovane insegnante cioè pochissimo tempo
fa il mio maestro il rettore della
scuola dove insegnavo mi sfidava
chiedendomi Ma tu Marco li educhi o gli
ecciti
una domanda in agirabile per Chiunque
abbia dei figli o lavori nella scuola
una domanda che per me è diventata
ancora più bruciante negli anni
trasformandosi in un'altra domanda ma tu
Marco li educhi o lieviti
per rispondere a queste terribili
domande penso che sia importante farsene
un'altra ma io genitore insegnante
educatore che cosa ho da offrire loro di
così essenziale da chiedere il loro
tempo perché i miei allievi dovrebbero
starmi ad ascoltare che cosa di così
importante da dare a loro da chiedere la
loro attenzione
e ancora di più Che cosa c'è nella
disciplina che in segno di così
fondamentale da chiedere il loro impegno
nello studio personale
Ecco dopo diversi anni di insegnamento e
tre figli sulle spalle
piccoli Ma tre ho individuato due
ingredienti fondamentali per la
fioritura dell'adolescente e sono
intelligenza e libertà
il primo fiore dell'umano è
l'intelligenza critica
attenzione per intelligenza Intendo
quella capacità di leggere dentro le
cose leggere
e insieme la capacità di collegare ogni
particolare alla totalità
vedere forme riconoscere relazioni ecco
cos'è l'intelligenza
L'intelligenza si muove lungo due canali
si esprime Cioè in due dimensioni che
talvolta dimentichiamo
il corpo e l'affetto e questo vale anche
per i logici puri o per i più nerd tra
gli informatici con tutto il rispetto
per gli informatici
L'intelligenza si dà cioè sempre sempre
nel corpo in cui è incarnata tanto che
il cervello arriva fin nelle mani
L'intelligenza non è mai astratta dalla
vita della nostra corporità
l'intelligenza poi è sempre affettiva
legata Cioè la dimensione del sentimento
del cuore si conosce in fondo solo ciò
che si ama
Ecco mani e cuore Altrimenti
l'intelligenza rimane rattrappita
impaurita inerte
grazie alla luce
dell'intelligenza incarnata e affettiva
possiamo finalmente vedere l'intero
delle cose facendo attenzione nel
presente a ciò che c'è Secondo la
totalità dei suoi aspetti
senza visione dell'intero L'intelligenza
si riduce a un freddo calcolo meccanico
senza attenzione al presente
l'intelligenza diventa miope e fa poi
violenza la realtà
il secondo fiore che ho scoperto la
libertà la libertà Certo come tutti
immaginiamo capacità di effettuare una
scelta ma per me più in profondità la
libertà è quella originaria capacità di
aderire all'essere di abbraccio a ciò
che ho davanti
la libertà come
aspettare qualcosa che mi dia la
felicità come il sentimento delle
infinite possibilità
la libertà ancora come capacità di agire
e di superare l'ostacolo il limite
aspirare all'infinito senza mai fermarsi
e risposte parziali
vivere nella libertà significa cercare
ad ogni istante ciò che può soddisfare
la nostra sete di felicità
e nella libertà tutto torna al suo posto
diritti e doveri giustizia e
Misericordia tornano amici
l'uomo e quindi ogni adolescente a
queste due architravi in sé da
riconoscere e da sviluppare pienamente
intelligenza e libertà
Ecco vediamo tutti Che intelligenza
Libertà oggi si sviluppano in un tempo
storico che sta cambiando radicalmente
sotto i nostri occhi
vorrei provare ad aiutarvi ricordandovi
quelle che per gli unsulano un filosofo
tedesco coreano sono gli aspetti propri
del nostro tempo della società e della
cultura in cui viviamo noi e i giovani
la performance come scopo dell'agire
individuale la riduzione della persona
ha un soggetto di prestazione
l'allontanamento la messa al bando il
più possibile del dolore e della
negatività la digitalizzazione sempre
maggiore dei modi di fare esperienza
il primato del calcolo algoritmico sulla
libertà individuale
e la sostituzione del criterio di verità
di verità con quello di
autodeterminazione assoluta di
visibilità di successo
sentiamo tutti Che intelligenza libertà
non crescono meccanicamente mai
soprattutto in un contesto come quello
che ho appena descritto ci sono ostacoli
di questa fioritura che vorrei provare a
portarvi e offrirvi
ostacoli che io ho scoperto nella mia
esperienza a scuola e fuori dalla scuola
ciò che impedisce la crescita di
intelligenza libertà è l'assenza di una
proposta competente appassionata
coinvolgente che mostra il senso di ciò
che si fa che si debba spiegare i
ragazzi l'analisi logica un problema di
matematica la Rivoluzione Francese la
proposta adeguata se chi la fa
Innanzitutto Si è chiesto cosa c'entri
quel contenuto con la realtà che senso
abbia quel contenuto con la realtà che i
ragazzi vivono e come sia possibile
comunicarlo a loro in modo efficace
ciò che
ciò che ostacolo l'intelligenza libertà
è un modo di giudicare
esclusivo escludente e distanziante
un modo di rapportarsi ai ragazzi fatto
di alternative radicali imposte e non
condivise nelle loro ragioni si deve non
si deve si fa non si fa si può non si
può prendi impara Devi farcela da solo
oppure non ce la farai mai da solo
non che non si debba dare loro
indicazioni e regole ma farlo sempre
condividendone le ragioni
questi fattori io ho individuato che
rendono insignificante Cioè senza
intelligenza e senza Libertà la
relazione educativa un eccitamento senza
ipotesi di significato un lavoro senza
coinvolgimento e passione delle regole
senza condivisione delle loro ragioni
cosa invece ci permette di educarli
davvero senza fermarci a eccitarli
momentaneamente o a evitarli anche se
con eleganza e apparente rispetto Ecco
cosa ho scoperto che favorisce
l'intelligenza la libertà dei ragazzi
primo la presenza di adulti che insieme
facciano loro la proposta di un
significato circa l'uomo e la realtà una
proposta da verificare nel tempo che
tocca insieme la mente il cuore e le
mani
dalla conoscenza del passato al progetto
fatto insieme in laboratorio all'uscita
sulla neve fino al volontariato e poi
aiutarli a scoprire criteri di giudizio
radicati nel loro cuore per non lasciare
i ragazzi alienati in balia delle prime
impressioni della voglia
dell'istintività
e poi mostrargli che ciò che conta nella
vita Lo sappiamo tutti è il percorso
sono le tappe del Cammino e non
soluzioni facili e immediate seminare
seminare seminare senza pretendere che
il raccolto venga con le nostre immagini
con i nostri tempi
e infine ciò che ritengo più importante
la dimensione comunitaria dell'esistenza
perché non ci si salva né si può
crescere da soli
attenzione a questa chi vive da solo o è
un animale selvatico o è un Dio diceva
Aristotele Perché l'uomo è un animale
costituito da relazioni Ecco perché per
educare Ci vuole un villaggio
possiamo Allora aiutare i nostri giovani
ponendogli le domande destando il loro
domande autentiche chi sono io che cos'è
la realtà che cos'è la verità Che cos'è
il bene che cos'è la giustizia Che cos'è
la bellezza e perché si nasce perché si
nasce perché si muore
aiutarli a trasformare i loro dubbi in
domande
Qual è la mia passione come posso essere
utile per il mondo come posso spendermi
per qualcosa di più grande
così la vita diventa un'avventura un
cammino fatto insieme a coloro a cui
domandiamo
domande che possano spalancargli e
spalancarci un Orizzonte infinito come
infinito è il loro Sé come infinito è il
loro intimo desiderio
i nodi in me in noi si sciolgono quando
sono davanti uno sguardo in cui
percepisco la mia infinità la mia
incommensurabilità la mia in
misurabilità rispetto a schemi
precostituiti la mia non ammanettabilità
immerso immersi in uno sguardo che non
ci definisce ci sentiamo liberi e
accettiamo finalmente noi stessi con i
limiti che abbiamo e la realtà anche
quando è dura
Insomma perché ciascuno adolescente
fiorisca serve Un'unica cosa L'amore che
si sperimenta in relazione amorevoli
io l'ho scoperto con Andrea e sì perché
tornato in classe triste dallo studio
della preside cosa ho fatto
l'ho guardato e con un po' di tenerezza
e un po' di ironia mi è venuto da dirgli
Andrea non ti preoccupare Farò di te un
grande uomo
con ironia e lui è andato al suo posto e
si è seduto mesi dopo venuto a dirmi che
quella frase tenera ironica aveva
scavato in lui e aveva destato e lui il
desiderio di cambiare di migliorarsi di
mettersi all'opera è diventato tra i
migliori della classe un punto di
riferimento per tutti i compagni e
ancora per me lo è oggi e lo saluto
Ecco perché Ecco perché allora sento
l'urgenza di un cambio di paradigma nel
modo di costruire la relazione a scuola
e nel lavoro perché ciascuno possa
essere intelligente e Libero
perché mi preoccupo tanto della
ricchezza della fama degli onori e non
mi preoccupo invece di farmi l'anima
buona
perché dentro uno sguardo libero e
amorevole
io posso ripercepire il mondo come dato
a me in ogni istante come fosse nuovo
per la prima volta buono per me
solo così avremo l'energia per
affrontare le sfide da cui siamo partiti
solo se noi in primis viviamo di domande
grandi di aspettative mai sazie sono
così potremo invitare i giovani sul
cammino della fioritura insieme a noi e
li vedremo anzi li vediamo intelligenti
e liberi perché voluti e Amati e quindi
creativi e responsabili sono così
troveranno il coraggio di mettere al
mondo dei figli e di prendersi cura
davvero del pianeta
insomma la fioritura di ciascuna
adolescente è la grande occasione per la
fioritura del pianeta ciascuno di noi in
fondo lo sa se quel ragazzo o quella
ragazza che è stato è fiorito o è
marcito o è ancora lì che attende di
fiorire E allora possiamo tutti tornare
con la memoria a quello sguardo in cui
abbiamo trovato vita intelligenza e
libertà e attenderlo ancora una volta a
domandarlo per noi ancora una volta
quello sguardo
perché nessun pianeta nessun successo
nessun indice di crescita vale la
fioritura di ogni singolo giovane che
scopre se stesso la fioritura di
ciascuno di noi grazie
[Applauso]